à Saint-Denis la rue Jean Châtel
s'appelait autrefois la rue Barachois
c'est aujourd'hui une longue artère
pleine de contraste résidentielle au sud
commerçant ensuite elle finit en
plongeant dans la mer le souvenir de
Jean Châtel a-t-il lui aussi sombré dans
l'océan
et planchâtel jean-châtel je crois
c'était un ancien maire mais je suis pas
sûr un grand nom bien sûr
une personnalité de la Réunion Châtel
Châtel les boissons
il y avait la maison Châtel qui
produisait les Roms les ponts etc je
connais les assurances
fils de pharmacien Jean Châtel né en mai
1884 bien que formé à la pharmacie le
jeune Jean se lance dans la distillerie
il crée les alcools Châtel en 1907
dynamique chef d'entreprise Jean Châtel
est aussi un homme de cœur qui va se
consacrer aux indigents il lance la
goutte de lait des arbres de Noël pour
les démunis des hospices pour les vieux
et des cantines scolaires en 1925 il est
élu maire de Saint-Denis un mandat qui
sera renouvelé trois fois mais il doit
démissionner de son fauteuil marial en
1937 pour raison de santé il retourne
aux affaires et selon cette fois dans
les assurances avec la préservatrice
après un voyage au Kerguelen où il
étudie les possibilités de pêche il
devient le président de la sa mère la
société anonyme de pêche malgache et
réunionnaise il dirige parallèlement la
distillerie de la rivière Dumas est
construit en 1944 la Société Jean Châtel
et compagnie au premier rang des
industriels il devient président de la
Chambre de commerce après l'assassinat
d'Alexis de Villeneuve la droite locale
le sort de sa retraite il remporte la
mairie de Saint-Denis devant Raymond
Vergès en juillet 1946 trois semaines
plus tard il est élu conseiller général
face au même adversaire mais Jean
chattel travaille trop de retour d'une
manifestation politique il meurt dans
son bureau de l'Hôtel de Ville le 27
avril 1948 c'est funérailles ont lieu le
lendemain à la cathédrale en présence
d'une foule considérable